la idea de que las personas con
discapacidades bien sean estás
cognoscitivas físicas sensoriales o de
cualquier orden sean incluidas en el
servicio público educativo es una idea
que goza hoy por hoy de una amplia
aceptación en la comunidad nacional e
internacional digamos que no existiría
una resistencia importante al pensar que
una persona ciega una persona sorda una
persona con parálisis cerebral en silla
de ruedas etcétera
tuviera acceso a la educación regular
porque consideramos que estas personas
tienen el derecho a ser incluidos en la
educación
pública
desde los años 90 sobre todo había una
notable influencia internacional en pro
de la inclusión educativa podríamos no
nombrar la conferencia mundial de la
educación para todos que fue celebrada
en john quién tailandia
posteriormente la declaración de
salamanca que fue convocada por la
unesco y el gobierno español y fue
firmada por 92 gobiernos del mundo en la
cual se definió que las personas con
discapacidades eran personas con
necesidades educativas especiales y en
esa medida debían ser atendidas en el
servicio público educativo atendiendo
estas necesidades educativas
posteriormente la conferencia de las
naciones unidas sobre las personas con
discapacidad o el informe mundial de la
discapacidad de la organización mundial
de la salud han seguido esta misma línea
digamos de la inclusión de las personas
con discapacidad que ha pasado en
colombia que ha pasado en nuestro país
en nuestro país también se ha acogido
esta tendencia como una política desde
la ley general de educación está
incluido un artículo completo en donde
habla de la inclusión educativa de
personas con limitaciones usaban esa
palabra en la ley con limitaciones
talentos excepcionales posterior a esa
ley
hubo diferentes decretos reglamentarios
sin embargo el hito más importante en
términos de la política educativa en
colombia me parece es más reciente está
con la ley 16 18 del año 2013 que es una
ley estatutaria en la cual se garantizan
los plenos derechos sociales de las
personas con discapacidad dentro de esos
derechos están incluidos los derechos a
la educación estamos todavía viviendo en
estos años las reglamentaciones
correspondientes
respecto a la inclusión educativa bien
entonces
pensar que una persona ciega debe ir a
una institución especializada en la
atención de personas ciegas o una
persona sorda debe ir a una institución
para sordos o una persona con síndrome
de dawn debe ir a una institución para
síndrome de dawn ya no es la idea más
aceptada no es la idea que tiene más
acogida en términos sociales ni en
términos profesionales porque porque
generalmente pensar la atención a las
personas con discapacidad si lleva a una
institucionalización de por vida de
estas personas con discapacidad con la
consecuente marginación de la vida
social y de la posibilidad de
desarrollar un proyecto vital
entonces este escenario para eso un
escenario ideal es decir uno diría
es perfecta la inclusión educativa hay
un consenso internacional que además ha
sido acogido nacionalmente se ha
desarrollado una política hay una ley
estatutaria sobre el tema de la
inclusión
luego la inclusión educativa fluye
adecuadamente en las escuelas pero
sabemos que esto no es así en la
realidad esto no opera así por qué
porque la cultura también tiene que ir
acompañando este cambio político no es
suficiente con un cambio en la política
es necesario un cambio cultural y en
esto en este cambio cultural los
profesionales que trabajamos con
discapacidad tenemos un rol bien
importante
en la cultura se circulan múltiples
representaciones sociales acerca de los
fenómenos de cualquier fenómeno estas
representaciones sociales nos definen la
forma en que comprendemos un fenómeno y
la forma como actuamos frente a ese
fenómeno en el caso de la discapacidad o
de la inclusión define la forma como
entendemos esa discapacidad o depende
entendemos esa inclusión y en
consecuencia la forma como nos
comportamos con respecto a ella los
profesionales de la de la discapacidad
también somos parte de la cultura y al
ser parte de la cultura también tenemos
representaciones acerca de la
discapacidad
esto cobra mucha importancia porque
dependiendo de las representaciones que
tengamos vamos a actuar no sólo en el
plano personal
nos pasa a todos
pero a los profesionales también estas
representaciones influyen en el plano
profesional en nuestras actuaciones
profesionales
voy a contarles unas historias de la
experiencia que he tenido trabajando en
estos años en la problemática digámoslo
así de la inclusión educativa la primera
vez que iba a hacer un proceso de
inclusión con una persona con
discapacidad se trataba de una niña de
12 años una niña que tenía una parálisis
cerebral la tf tóxica muy funcional
caminaba independientemente hablaba un
tono de voz un poco bajo pero audible
una niña inteligente pues aquí viene el
primer gran cuestionamiento y que hace
una niña de 12 años con estas
características en una institución de
educación especial y rehabilitación
urge llevarla a la inclusión educativa
hay que llevarla a un colegio
para que continúe su proceso
entonces empezamos trabajamos con la
niña la fuimos preparando trabajamos con
su familia ubicamos una institución
educativa en donde habían estudiado sus
dos hermanas mayores se habían graduado
de allí y el colegio quedaba cerca a su
casa pero el colegio público grande más
de mil personas más de 1000 estudiantes
en el colegio como era la primera vez
que yo hacía un proceso de inclusión
educativa pues dije asesoremos los de
una experta nacional en el tema y esto
fue lo que me dijo la experta
la recomendación que dio es que ese
colegio no era adecuado para la
inclusión educativa el grupo legión muy
grande de tal forma que la inclusión
había que hacer un colegio pequeño para
que fuera más fácil para la niña y fuera
más fácil también para la institución
la quietud la inquietud que me dejó esta
recomendación
era referente a cuál es el objetivo de
la inclusión educativa si el objetivo de
la inclusión educativa es hacer el
proceso fácil
o si es producir un cambio social más
grande no sólo para las niñas en general
para la sociedad
se hablaba mucho el principio de
normalización en esa época que dice que
hay que tratar de hacer la vida de la
persona lo más normal posible de acuerdo
a sus características y a sus
condiciones personales y sociales
entonces mi razonamiento fue no existe
ninguna razón ninguna condición en la
niña para que no pueda ir a un colegio
grande no entendí que hubiera allí
ninguna dificultad
entonces oída la asesora y se lo que se
considere y la niña fue al colegio
grande empezamos el proceso en el
colegio que habíamos ubicado preparamos
las directivas los profesores los
futuros compañeros de la niña y fuimos
al proceso de inclusión escolar un par
de semanas después primera asesoría con
la directora del grupo la directora del
grupo en que estaba la niña
y me dejó fuera de base la inquietud de
la profesora yo esperaba que la
profesora me preguntara cómo hago para
manejar esta situación en el aula cómo
hago para enseñarle tal concepto que se
me está dificultando como fomento la
participación de la niña en las
actividades del aula y las actividades
escolares en general pero no era la
inquietud que la profesora tenía en el
momento la inquietud de la profesora era
cómo hago para que la niña tenga el
cuello derecho
estaba empeñada de muy buena fe estaba
empeñada en tratar de que la niña
tuviera el cuello derecho tarea que era
imposible porque era una condición
propia de su discapacidad es decir ella
nunca va a tener el cuello derecho bueno
pues la asesoría se orientó a que la
profesora entendiera que la estudiante
con discapacidad era una estudiante y
que los aspectos relacionados con la
rehabilitación física se la dejaremos a
los fisioterapeutas a los ortopedistas a
los fisiatras y nosotros nos centramos
en la inclusión educativa propiamente
dicha
posteriormente en otros procesos
trabajamos con los maestros de apoyo los
maestros de apoyo son profesores pueden
ser educadores educadores especiales
psicólogos a veces fonoaudiólogos
terapeutas ocupacionales que están en
los colegios que tienen inclusión para
favorecer el proceso de inclusión esto
maestros de apoyo reuniendo a los
muchachos que tenían discapacidad y que
estaban en el colegio y les decían esto
fíjense ustedes que los maestros de
apoyo
le decían a los estudiantes que el
problema y el éxito de la inclusión
dependía de ellos de su esfuerzo
personal
los profesores no saben de la inclusión
los profesores no saben de discapacidad
no tienen por qué saberlo
usted es el que tiene que incluirse
pues aquí viene otra gran inquietud y es
cuál es el propósito de la inclusión el
propósito de la inclusión es que la
escuela se quede igual
y que solamente por esfuerzo personal
las personas logren permanecer en una
escuela
fíjense ustedes que ellos son
profesionales que tienen unas
representaciones y actúan con base en
estas representaciones la actuación
problemática aquí está en que su acción
profesional se centraba casi
exclusivamente en la atención de las
propias personas con discapacidad a
veces su familia
pero se obviaba mucho el trabajo con
profesores el trabajo con directivas el
trabajo en términos generales con la
institución educativa
bien qué pasa entonces con la propia
persona con discapacidad resulta que hay
una persona que ya está incluida en un
proceso exitoso de inclusión educativa
ya casi va a terminar su bachillerato le
había ido muy bien y entonces me dice lo
siguiente
si ustedes ven la narrativa de lo que
dice esta persona que tiene discapacidad
ella piensa más o menos parecido a cómo
piensan los maestros de apoyo
es decir lo importante es la
representación de la superación personal
entonces el éxito de la inclusión no
está en que las escuelas tengan la
capacidad de incluir en que la sociedad
sea inclusiva etcétera sino en que la
persona logre superar sus problemáticas
no solamente asociadas a la discapacidad
como tal cuando una onda en esto
encuentra que son muchas problemáticas
más de índole psicológicas que ella
misma ubica por supuesto las personas
con discapacidad también son parte de la
cultura y también tienen
representaciones sociales
entonces
fíjense ustedes que el proceso viene
como en cadena
los profesionales de la discapacidad
no solamente los que trabajan en
términos de la inclusión educativa todos
los que trabajamos o trabajan en
rehabilitación incluso profesionales de
la salud
tenemos un papel muy importante que
jugar aquí
porque la inclusión no es llevar al niño
a la escuela sino la inclusión es
favorecer el desarrollo realmente de una
sociedad incluyente de una sociedad
inclusiva entonces
los invito a hacerse las siguientes
preguntas todos los que sean aquí
profesionales de la discapacidad
profesionales que atiendan a las
personas con discapacidad y los que no
también
vamos a hacernos las siguientes
preguntas
primera
soy consciente del importante papel que
tengo en la construcción de una cultura
de la inclusión
otra pregunta reconozco las
representaciones sociales que tengo
acerca de la discapacidad
y sobre todo reconozco la forma como
estas representaciones sociales influyen
en mi actuación profesional
vamos con una tercera pregunta
propició cambios en la institución
educativa cambios en las prácticas
curriculares
cambios en las prácticas pedagógicas aún
cambios en las prácticas administrativas
escolares de manera que la institución
educativa esté cada vez más preparada
para atender a personas con
discapacidades y sin discapacidades
y una tercera pregunta
refuerza la idea
de que la inclusión educativa es un
problema de la persona con discapacidad
y no de la institución educativa y de la
sociedad
la respuesta a estas preguntas nos dará
pistas
sobre la manera como nosotros como
profesionales estamos contribuyendo
realmente en una inclusión y en una
inclusión educativa en particular muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]